some lawmakers are calling for a popular
flea and tick collar to be pulled from
store shelves a congressional
subcommittee is launching an
investigation
and calling for a temporary recall of
this series of flea
and tick collar after thousands of
reports that it may have made
pets and even people very ill our
consumer investigative correspondent
anna werner has more anna good morning
to you
we're not only talking about sick pets
we understand the collar may actually be
linked to the deaths of nearly
1700 pets good morning to you
good morning right and those reports
went to the epa which regulates
pesticides now the agency
has not concluded that these callers
pose any danger
but people reported to them and on
social media
that their pets became ill or died and
many of them believe
that the callers are to blame
four-month-old kittens oscar and felix
were healthy says owner karen pizzano
until she put ceresto collars on them
and within two days oscar's legs began
twitching
and that's when i became extremely
alarmed on a veterinarian's advice she
says she immediately removed the collars
but oscar died that night you think
you're doing
the best thing for your pets to protect
them
and to see this poor thing see him pass
you didn't deserve that i believe it was
that call i absolutely do
jerry kurtz says his 135-pound dog baron
was healthy as a horse
until he put a ceresto collar on him
within 12 hours
he had a massive massive seizure he was
foaming with his
mouth his eyes was rolled back kurt says
a veterinarian
gave barron anti-seizure medication but
the seizures continued
getting so bad a year later he says he
felt he had to put baron to sleep
i loved that dog i just wasn't right
it's collars contain two pesticides to
ward off ticks and fleas
retailer elanco says the callers are
safe
but government documents obtained by a
non-profit group
show since ceresto callers were
introduced in 2012
more than 75 000 incidents have been
reported to the epa
ranging from skin irritation to seizures
plus
nearly 1700 pet deaths senior scientist
nathan donnelly
the biggest thing that stuck out to me
was just how high these numbers are
elanco disputes that saying the incident
report rate in the u.s has been below
0.3 percent
and the majority relate to non-serious
effects such as skin
problems a company official said that a
report is not an indication of cause
and said there's no established link
between exposure to the active
ingredients in suresto and pet deaths
but congressman raja krishnamoorthy
wants the callers off the market
at least temporarily i think that it's
only
appropriate in this case that the
manufacturer
do a voluntary recall the situation has
to be investigated
and that's why we're taking action as we
are right now
well the company says it's cooperating
with the subcommittee but will not
be uh hosting a voluntary recall that it
says would be up to regulators
the epa says it's in conversation with
elinco about these
incidents um and it should be noted that
many veterinarians continue to recommend
these products now if you have a story
to tell us about this issue or
anything else you can email us at
consumer cbsnews.com
tony you can really feel for those pet
owners we hope we get to the bottom of
this anna thank you very much